when we signed up to be deep sea
fishermen what'd they tell us they gave
us a dude's e-mug and they said someday
we might find a Darby tangled up in our
Nets well today was that day Darby day
and this Darby's not in good shape his
memory shot doesn't know where he is
doesn't know who he is the only thing he
knows is that he's got to get back to
the North Sea in 48 hours or a worldwide
extinction level event will be triggered
that can be seen from space and I know
we got a cargo hold full of brown crab
and I know we got a category five
hurricane between us and the North Sea
and I know you hate jar of beers this is
bigger than what happened to you when
you were 10. we have to turn this boat
around and save this goddamn dog come on
for once in your life do a good job
boner
oh
oh you're in Darby that was me yes
I think that was you okay